avec le tir d'un missile anti satellite
russe en croire les médias français
c'est un nouvel épisode de star wars qui
est en cours le kremlin contre attaque
et si on allait au delà des titres plus
effrayants les uns que les autres pour
voir ce qui s'est passé exactement
le ministère russe de la défense a mené
avec succès le 15 novembre un test de
missiles antisatellites détruisant
appareil spatial russe céline a des qui
était en orbite depuis
1982 et ne fonctionnait plus le ministre
russe a souligné que les débris du
satellite ont été inclus dans le
catalogue principal du système national
de contrôle de l'espace est
immédiatement pris en charge jusqu'à ce
qu'ils soient détruits quant au danger
supposé pour la station spatiale
internationale selon la modélisation du
ministère russe de la défense les débris
évolue selon des traits victoire est
désormais vide qui évite les ss qui se
trouve 40 ou 60 km plus bas que les
fragments de l'appareil mais les
explications des autorités russes n'ont
évidemment pas suffi au département
d'état américain
pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui la
fédération de russie imprudemment
procéder à un essai de destructeur d'un
missiles antisatellites ascension
directe contre l'un de ses propres
satellites ce test a généré à ce jour
plus de 1500 débris orbitaux traçable et
des centaines de milliers de débris
orbitaux plus petits qui menace
désormais les intérêts de toutes les
nations
la sincérité des inquiétudes américaines
pour les intérêts de toutes les nations
n'a pas toutefois convaincu le chef de
la diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
affirmé que la russie est à l'origine de
risques qui pèserait sur l'utilisation
pacifique de l'espace révèle pour le
moins de l'hypocrisie comme vous l'avez
justement remarquer il n'y a aucune
preuve de cela mais je vais vous donner
d'autres faits les etats-unis nous
appelle comme ils le disent à développer
des normes universelles pour
l'exploration spatiale mais depuis des
années négligent l'initiative de la
russie et de la chine concernant la
préparation de l'accord sur la
prévention de la course aux armements
dans l'espace il la néglige tout
simplement en insistant sur
l'établissement des normes de conduite
néanmoins les etats-unis eux-mêmes
développe cette course aux armements
très activement
pour ceux qui aiment détient dans
l'espace que la presse semble avoir
découvert cette semaine uniquement et
convient de rappeler que ce dernier
était loin d'être le premier du genre
le 26 mars 2019 l'inde a abattu son
appareil spatial en orbite terrestre
basse à 300 km d'altitude à l'aide d'un
missile balistique
le premier ministre n'a rien de rameau
dit a déclaré que la destruction du
satellite était intervenue moins de
trois minutes après le lancement de la
fusée le 11 janvier 2007 la chine a
également détruit un satellite
météorologique hors service en orbite ce
qui a généré plus de 40000 des bribes le
20 février 2008 et les états unis ont
utilisé un missile antimissile pour
détruire leurs satellites usa 193 et le
9 juillet 1962 les etats-unis ont fait
exploser à 400 km d'altitude en missiles
terme au nucléaire coeur d'une puissance
d'un 1,4 mégatonnes à la suite de
l'explosion une importante ceinture de
rayonnement ses formes et obligeant à
ajuster les paramètres des vols des
vaisseaux spatiaux russes voskhod
pendant deux ans
[Musique]
cela augmente vraiment la mise si vous
voulez pour ce genre de guerre d'une
part et d'autre part cela représente
vraiment une militarisation de l'espace
extra atmosphérique
cela étant dit je dirais que la chine et
les etats unis ont également démontré
cette capacité
il n'y a donc pas que la russie et je
pense que c'est d'autant plus la raison
pour laquelle les pays capables de cette
percée technologique doivent travailler
ensemble pour essayer de s'assurer que
l'espace ne soit pas militarisée
mais ce génie est peut-être déjà sorti
de sa bouteille et je pense que ce sera
le nouveau domaine de la guerre elle
nous avons déjà entendu l'otan même
parler de l'espace comme de leur
prochain domaines de préoccupation en
termes de futurs objectifs de guerre
c'est donc une technologie qui peut
d'une part servir la paix mais d'une
autre part elle peut servir la guerre et
quand on a cette capacité cela peut
constituer une évolution alarmante
c est une réalité depuis un moment mais
la russie est loin d'être seul
génériques